hello i'm reza aslan and i'm rayne
wilson and i'm here to remind you that
the earth is dying and we're killing it
jesus dude sorry i know that got dark
god damn well [ __ ] it then i'm leaving
no no no no no there may be something
that we can do about it about the
potential destruction of everything we
know do you want to get into it yes
please okay here we go
[Music]
[Music]
so the changes that humanity needs to
make
uh are
legion it's as big as you can possibly
imagine
buying a bunch of cheap crap and just
throwing it and having a huge carbon
footprint and just building willy-nilly
and ripping down trees
and
killing off species is not going to cut
it it's going to if we continue in that
behavior uh hundreds of millions of
people are going to lose their lives
well i mean talk about the most
important spiritual and existential
issue that we could possibly address
this is it yeah it's the big one this is
the big one it's the big one and i just
read an article today that was talking
about denial and there's three different
kinds of denial so the number one denial
is like it's not happening and people
don't really go there anymore that's the
republicans right no i mean there's some
yeah but the
hoax but that's the second kind of
denial is like hey don't overreact we
don't need to change our lifestyle that
much you're just making a mountain out
of a molehill
there's always going to be some climate
change here and there it's going to not
going to be that bad and kind of like a
lot of obfuscation and talking points
that kind of take away from the
seriousness of the problem so that's the
center of that a lot second level of
denial but the third level of denial are
well-meaning folks like our podcast
listeners like me which are simply not
really looking at it because we don't
know what to do and we don't really want
to face the fact that's me
that it is a world crisis how is that
you
that's me like i feel i feel overwhelmed
by it i feel like
the the amount of change that's
necessary in order to fix the problem
uh
requires a kind of political will that i
just
don't believe is possible so um this is
what i did i went up to greenland
um and i'm while i'm up there shooting
this little thing i was like why don't i
record a [ __ ] podcast brah what was
greenland like what was it like
it's crazy man i mean
i think there's like 35 000 people in
the entire country and the country is
like bigger than texas wow it is huge
there is zero arable land on greenland
what do people eat then you you eat
seals
they eat they're walking around with
dead seals in plastic bags i'm not
kidding you in all the towns did you did
you eat some soup i i couldn't bring
myself to eat the seal
chewy i would imagine very chewy very
very chewy it's be like chewing on a raw
molasses instead you just hit the local
taco bell yeah and yeah i didn't yeah
but it's it's crazy i mean it's um
it's so desolate
um and when that really desolate space
becomes super beautiful uh it's very
still there oddly enough there's like
very little wind in greenland so
some of the light the sunsets i saw
northern lights for the first time in my
life uh
unbelievable the people were really
kind and warm
and um
it's just the edge of the earth it
really is it's like it's like nothing
i've ever seen before
[Music]
so um i spoke to david hick and gail
whiteman
and uh they're two
wonderful scientists they're passionate
about climate change they're so
knowledgeable and unlike most kind of
nerdy
kind of laboratory-based scientists
these are ones that are really trying to
communicate what they know to the
outside world and really trying to do
something david hick is a professor of
biological sciences at the university of
alberta he studies terrestrial ecology
and as an expert climate scientist in in
in arctic systems both of them uh focus
on the arctic because the arctic is the
bell weather of climate change
everything that's happening in the world
that's going to be happening in the
world is going to be felt in the arctic
first so that's where scientists are
turning their attention gail whiteman dr
gail whiteman is director of the
pentland center for sustainability and
business at lancaster university in the
uk she's the founder of arctic base camp
uh which i am a board member of a
non-profit uh which goes to davos and um
sets up this really cool arctic base
camp unit at davos so the billionaires
are flying in on their private jets and
trying to show them the science of
climate change um
and
she is an expert on global risk
and i sat down with the two of them
together in a hotel room in ilulasat
greenland
with
icebergs floating around no kidding no
exaggeration in the ocean out outside
and seals swimming around and whales
spouting around and i sat down with the
two of them together to talk about how
our world and our humanity is changing
and i tried to make the conversation not
like your normal typical climate change
conversation oh boo boo this is bad and
you know but to really get into
kind of the life's big question that
underlies it which is
humanity has done
certain things
that has led to this point and how do we
shift that how do we shift what humanity
is doing on this planet to move forward
it's the ultimate existential question
how did we get here where are we going
[Music]
hi podcast listeners hello metaphysical
milkshake hi reza
uh this podcast is coming to you from
room 511 of the arctic hotel in lulasat
greenland north of the arctic circle uh
where i'm sitting with two
world-renowned scientists and just so
the listeners know we have just spent 12
hours out in
in greenland uh exploring exploring
nature uh we took a boat ride
70 kilometers north of alulasat uh
to
i don't even know what it's called it
has some ridiculous greenlandic name but
uh
a giant glacier meeting the ocean and it
about a kilometer and a half long it
looked like the wall from game of
thrones it really did was it 300 feet
tall i'm guessing at least at least and
uh the noises it was making
i think would have fit very well in game
of thrones as well it really truly was
some noises that i have never heard
before in my life the sound of a glacier
cracking
calving pieces of it falling off into
the ocean kind of groaning of ice and
then the constant because we were like
in a sea of ice cubes it was just chunks
so we did that then we visited a
greenlandic village we were on a boat
for hours and hours now and it's 9 30 at
night so we're a little bit tired a
little bit punch trunk but what better
time to dig into some of life's biggest
possible questions having to do with
climate change taking a giant step back
and looking at humanity on this planet
we've got the dawn of the industrial age
how do how did we get to where we are
right now
well i think we got here because people
wanted a better life
so they tried to find ways to make life
easier and certainly at any time in any
part of human history if you find an
easier way to conserve energy
and get more food in an easier way
people will do it every culture has done
that
the the problem we have right now though
is that it was fossil fuels and a little
bit of fossil fuel use was okay it just
has been far too much for too long and
it's really changed you know the
atmosphere
well and and
i think what
really made it possible for us to get to
this point is that for the last 10 000
years the climate system's been pretty
stable normally it bounces all over the
place in and out of glacial periods and
we've been since the end of the last ice
age in a time when
that variability has been reduced and
that allowed societies to establish and
most importantly perhaps the the
development of of agriculture
and we've gone through several
agricultural revolutions and maybe we
can come back to this later but i think
this ability to take nature and tame it
in a way that allowed us to
have time
to
develop science to develop culture
to
um
you know increase our populations
has been a catalyst for the type of
innovation that has got us to this point
and
i don't know what you think gail but i
think we're reaching a point where that
innovation is creating more problems
than it's solving yeah like i don't
think it's innovation on its own it's
just exploitation without understanding
the unintended consequences right right
so and then really not looking at them
even when they're glaringly obvious so i
think innovation alone is a real
strength it's like that basic curiosity
kids have is a good thing
and aren't we going to rely on
innovation to take us
out of this in some regard at some point
in time absolutely i think we will but i
think that our motivation
for doing that can't be singularly
economic
it can't be about a small
profit
for short-term gain whether that's
distributed evenly across you know
society or population or not but it's
about why are we why are we innovating
and and what what is the benefit of
being clever as a species and being able
to apply that knowledge to
uh
make the world a better place make
make ourselves richer and i think it's
funny because gail at first you said and
it sounded so reasonable you were like
oh
we people want a more comfortable life
you know and
uh and then you and then you talked
about exploiting resources so
we wanted a more and and david you said
we wanted to tame the world you know
i think that we i'm not the scientist
and i'm asking you to step outside of
your distinctive specific fields a
little bit but i'm not really a
scientist but i'm not at all a scientist
in fact i'm whatever a scientist is i'm
the opposite of whatever that thing is
so
um
so
but from my point of view it's all about
that taming and exploitation this idea
that nature
was something to be tamed that nature
was something to be exploited as if we
had that right
there was something
i don't know you know i think if reza
was sitting here he'd probably blame
christianity but
there was something taken away from the
the primal indigenous
people's beliefs that mother earth is
sacred and we need to treat her with
great respect
and we're so busy taming and exploiting
and seeking comfort and
acting out of greed that
some kind of
you know
maybe not climate some kind of
environmental disaster was inevitable
well you know i lived with indigenous
people for two years while i was doing
my field research for my phd
and i think the thing i the first thing
i learned was it was super not romantic
it's really hard and you are looking for
ways to make life easier right when
you're hauling water out of um frozen
lakes just to have drinking water you
are looking for things that could make
it easier so the idea of of convenience
is is good at the same time there was
such a deep appreciation that you were
just one part of a web of life that you
were inside it and that by recognizing
that actually you were able to be more
successful
and i think because if you didn't know
what was going on if you couldn't read
the tracks of the animals or understand
where the ice was or understand um
uh weather coming in then you were
vulnerable and you were at risk so the
idea of being part of that web of life
actually gave you you know what business
would say is a competitive advantage uh
and i think embedding yourself is is is
you know a really deep strength that
these cultures have
and i think in in the last few hundred
years we've lost that attachment
to the rest of the world we don't
recognize ourselves as being part of
nature as being part of a food web
and yeah we're at the top of it
sometimes but
when we
disassociate ourselves from the rest of
the natural world
and position ourselves as being in
control of everything
then
we get to a point where we are now where
we don't we we've really lost control of
the changes that are occurring and a
good
a good first step would be to
re-establish that respect for the
natural world and gail that was
interesting what you said because you
almost said like there's a cost-benefit
analysis
to
recognizing
oneself in the web of life that actually
if you
uh have a certain humility about seeing
yourself in this complicated web and
part of it of a much larger very fragile
interdependent ecosystem
that the payoff is much greater than if
you disassociate yourself from it yeah i
mean i think that that was something
that i really
learned you know the hard way when i was
living in the bush camp the first day i
went up there i was not paying enough
attention to the natural environment and
to where i was and i nearly died because
i was completely unable to make sense of
fast-moving changes in the ecology and i
was paying attention to the people so i
was socially focused but not
ecologically focused and then i realized
that while i started to pay attention to
a lot more and built up my skills in a
very routine way it was both comforting
actually
and
you know you just got better at it and
you could get resources and and you
could get you know your family could
survive in a harsh winter of you know
minus 30 day time celsius daytime
temperature minus 50 at night i mean
that's cold
milkshakers is the piece of plastic in
your wallet doing enough for you because
with the secured chime credit builder
visa credit card you can start building
credit with everyday purchases and
on-time payments you see with credit
builder members can increase their
credit history with no annual fees or
interest and having a good credit score
can mean getting better car loan rates
or renting apartments easier or
just bragging rights around the dinner
table so continue your credit journey
with chime
sign up only takes two minutes it
doesn't affect your credit score get
started at chime dot com slash milkshake
that's chime dot com
slash milkshake the chime credit builder
visa credit card is issued by stride
bank n a pursuant to a license from visa
usa chime checking account and two
hundred dollars qualifying direct
deposit required to apply for the
secured chime credit builder visa credit
card regular on-time payment history can
have a positive impact on your credit
score impact to score may vary and some
user scores may not improve
rain uh
how many podcasts have we now done about
the climate crisis like 70
i don't know yeah maybe something like
that have something to do i mean look we
talk about it a lot
because we're obsessed with it it's very
important we have to figure out a way to
get people to start caring about the
climate crisis to start changing their
uh actions and their activities to to
really inspire other people to act and
that's what's so great about ren
ren folks is a startup that's making it
easy for everyone to make a meaningful
difference in the climate crisis right
now they're focused on monthly
subscriptions where you can calculate
your carbon footprint then offset it by
supporting awesome climate projects that
plant trees protect rainforests and
remove co2 from the sky signing up for
ren is an easy way to do something
meaningful about the climate crisis
ren practices something called hyper
transparency that means once you sign up
to make a monthly contribution to offset
your carbon footprint you'll receive
monthly updates about the tree planting
rainforest protection or the carbon
removal projects that you're funding you
can even see the exact coordinates of
the trees you planted unbelievable i
know look it's going to take all of us
to end the climate crisis you can do
your part today by signing up for rent
so go to ren
dot co
slash milkshake sign up and they'll
plant 10 extra trees in your name that's
w-r-e-n
dot c-o
slash
milkshake start making a difference
thank you ren
so you were working with the james bay
cree
uh for those two years
did you what are there more specific
life lessons about ecology that you
gleaned from the cree people and their
traditions when you were living and
working there
yeah i think you know the first thing i
really learned was that you had to
really understand the place where you
were
and the place was both the ecology but
the people
and the spirit world so there was a
dynamic that was going on
um in their belief system where they
were actually in conversation with their
local ecology in conversation like we're
in conversation
and whether
we believe that or i believe that is not
what's important is they believed that
and there was a successful strategy for
them they lived there for thousands and
thousands of years and the hunter that i
was staying with his family you know you
could drop him in to
the middle of the subarctic winter with
an axe and he could survive that winter
he still had those skills it was
amazing so in conversation with nature
like talking to trees and then also in
the conversation with the spirit world
and talking to the spirits around them
yeah
wow
with us in the western world in our
culture right now we don't really talk
to trees or talk to spirits maybe we
should be doing more of that i don't
mean to denigrate that at all
but how do we
commune with our ecological systems in
this day and age how do we
get out of this mentality of subjugating
nature
exploiting nature for our own comfort
without any kind of
thought of the future
one example
that is really resonating for me right
now in in the communities i work with
one easy way for us to or very simple
direct way for us to reattach some
meaning to to the world is to use some
of the indigenous names
so for example there's a big different
uh big difference between calling
something say cloney lake versus
clue on mon
big fish lake
and the mountains around
have names of animals or animal spirits
or the rivers that flow into those lakes
have names that you know have nothing to
do with the dead horse that died there
100 years ago and you know slims river
right so we need to we need to think
about
the spiritual attachment of place
to the environment and when we come in
as colonizers or we come in uh as
tourists or we come in without that
attachment without paying attention to
the attachment
that evolves over
a long period of time
and it could be indigenous
first nations it could be residents of a
place the local community that have
generations of of of attachment and
stories
those are the things that connect us
back and i think we need to slow down a
little bit and pay attention to
understanding the landscape around us
it's changed over time it'll continue to
change but understanding
what to call a place and why it's called
what it is is really an
important aspect of of learning to
respect the place as well it's beautiful
yeah i would agree and i think that it's
this idea of also
attachment but then also
deep daily routine
knowledge
of where you are and the ecology and how
that's changing around you
and i think that's important so i used
to teach my mba students and my business
students in an outdoor classroom on
sustainability and i taught it outside
because i wanted them for maybe the
first time
in a long time to pay attention to the
natural environment where they were as
opposed to the natural environment was
for leisure was for recreation was for
sports was for travel on their way to
work or school and i wanted them to
think that that's a place of work
and we actually have to pay attention to
what the weather is like routinely
people would say what do we what do i
wear and i'm like we'll figure out what
the weather is going to be like and
dress accordingly so it's not that
nature is away somewhere and we can come
inside and just be away and talk about
sustainability in a denatured place we
have to be in it and i and i think that
that's really important to try and
figure out what are these little changes
that over time become huge changes and
and we can see that we saw that in in
one of the villages today that that some
of the the local people had been
noticing climate change 25 years ago
they didn't know what it meant but they
they noticed something was different and
they tried to figure out what that was
and if there was risk and how they could
somehow adapt to that risk
and that's where we are now because the
rest of us have not really been doing
that it's interesting it's in speaking
to ole today the native greenlander
who's from that village of 30 people
used to be 200 people
he was talking about how there's so much
more fish
recently
and there's so many more whales recently
it's just the places chock-a-block with
whales and then he was talking about
how he wishes they could hunt the whales
the way their ancestors did because they
only have a limit on greenland can only
have like 12 whales per year or
something like that but they've been
hunting whales for thousands of years
and one whale could feed the city of
elusitat for like a month you know but
instead he was talking about instead we
ship in and plane in pork and chicken
and beef cows that were grown in on
another continent and they're not
allowed to to to harvest their whale but
the point that i'm the larger point i'm
trying to make is that
climate change is pushing all the little
fish north into colder waters and all
the larger fish are chasing all the
little fish so all the fish are
migrating seemingly up from the equator
up into colder and colder waters and
it's changing the whole ecology it
happens to be really helping their
fishing industry the fishermen are like
making money hand over fist up here but
uh he also recognized like the glaciers
are retreating the great glaciers are
shrinking and melting
it's very true you know
one of the challenges we face in the
future i think is erasing some of the
lines that we've dropped drawn on the
map because the fish don't know where
the boundaries are between the economic
zones of greenland and canada and
iceland or anywhere else
bears don't know when they've crossed
from canada into the u.s or from
alaska into the yukon
and trees and you know other species
don't know that their
their limits of their range
is here and that they become invasive
when they go somewhere else and create
all sorts of problems and we have to
this this porosity of nature
over time is
is part of the whole evolutionary
process it's part of that adaptation
process and one of the challenges i see
is we've drawn boundaries
um
uh political boundaries economic
boundaries social boundaries that that
don't acknowledge
that that flow of
um
of the climate system of the ecology of
the world across those boundaries and i
think a good starting point would be to
recognize that those are things we've
imposed and maybe they had a moment when
they were appropriate for some reason
but there are barriers now for us being
able to look forward and and change with
the rest of the world
folks if you've recently bought anything
you've probably noticed that prices have
gone up on almost everything especially
on essentials like gas groceries and
utilities and that's why it's a great
time to use good rx
to at least save on your prescription
costs how well with goodrx you can
instantly compare prescription prices at
pharmacies in your neighborhood and find
discounts that could save you up to
eighty percent eighty percent people
good rx is free and easy to use and it
works whether you do or do not have
insurance even if you have insurance
goodrx may actually beat your copay
price
you can check goodrx online or on their
app which just happens to be one of the
most downloaded medical apps from there
you can find prescription savings at
over 70 000 pharmacies nationwide like
cvs walgreens rite aid vaughn's walmart
and many more then take the money that
you've saved with goodrx and put it
towards filling your tank or
filling your shopping cart or anything
else that has gotten more expensive
these days which is just about
everything right i have spoken to many
people that have personally used goodrx
and they love it they like to price
compare and price shop
their medicines just like you would
anything else i mean why not genius idea
right
for simple smart savings and your
prescriptions check goodrx go to good
rx.com milkshake that is good
rx.com
milkshake
goodrx.comshake goodrx is not insurance
but can be used in place of insurance
medicare and medicaid in 2021 goodrx
users saved 81
on retail prescription prices
element is a tasty electrolyte drink mix
with everything you need and nothing you
don't that means lots of salt with no
sugar
it contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio 1000 milligrams of sodium 200
milligrams potassium 60 milligrams
magnesium but with none of the junk that
means no sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients no gluten no fillers no bs
so when you sweat the primary
electrolyte lost is sodium and you can
lose up to seven grams per day when
sodium isn't replaced it's common to
experience muscle cramps and fatigue
i've been using these now
for the last several months because they
sent me a
sample i'd love it
i have less
muscle cramps and fatigue after my epic
tennis battles with elements so i really
appreciate what they do the element is
so sure you will love their product and
come back for more that they're offering
you a free element sample pack that's
eight single serving packets i got a
bunch of these it's great there's like a
whole bunch of variety
and it's all free all you got to do is
cover the cost of shipping which is yeah
about five bucks for u.s customers so
you can get yours at
drinkelement.com
milkshake now that's drink
l m n t c clever right elementy element
get it
drink
lmnt.com milkshake this deal is not
available on their regular website so
you've got to go to drinkelement.com
milkshake element offers a no questions
asked refund try it totally risk-free if
you don't like it share it with a salty
friend and they'll give you your money
back no questions asked you got nothing
to lose except dehydration
one of the things you said today when
we're out on our boat under that glacier
which i thought was so interesting is
you were talking about how there's a
whole as you study ecosystems
among other things but there's a whole
ecosystem under the ice
so when the sea ice melts
what happens so talk us through that
because we went through an interesting
conversation of like
tracing that and i don't think people i
had never really thought about stuff
like that yeah well i think i think one
of the the changes that's taking place
fairly rapidly that that most people are
aware of is the loss
of uh sea ice in the arctic um from
historically about eight million square
kilometers to about half of that and a
sustained loss year after year
in the last decade
and not just are we losing the ice in
summer but the ice is getting younger it
doesn't stick around long enough to
become old ice and that old ice develops
a really highly productive unique
ecosystem
on the bottom surface you know that's
that's in the water column and that
serves as sort of a nursery for all
sorts of
uh of species that feed on algae that
feed on zooplankton
small fishes that are eaten by big
fishes that are eaten by seals that are
eaten by polar bears there's this whole
system that that sort of relies on on on
that part of the community
to to to sustain it
if you lose that old sea ice and you
lose sea ice in general that that all
disappears
and so the nature of the entire arctic
ocean food web is going to change at the
same time so that's one example when you
say change
it's going to change for the worst
because there are going to be animals
that are going to miss out and just not
have
their food and will be seriously hurt or
go extinct there is nowhere else for
them to go that's correct right and
they'll be replaced by something else
but we'll have lost something at the
same time right and diversity is really
the
one of the fundamental pillars of
sustainability and and resilience but
it's interesting that we talk about
unity and diversity as a spiritual
concept we talk about the importance of
diversity like in the united states that
you know the conversation about the
importance of diversity and diversity
makes us stronger
as a as a race
on this planet i mean as a as a race
meaning a species on this planet um but
also
uh seems like that diversity also works
in nature that uh
nature thrives on diversity and because
we're part of nature we need it too
in all forms and the science is showing
really clearly that biodiversity is at
is far over the safe operating space
it's hugely at risk you know one out of
eight species are at risk of extinction
tremendously big millions of species are
at risk because of what we're doing and
that is just bad news for the the planet
and also the space in which we operate
or thrive as humans human society i
don't want to forget the doom and gloom
i actually really like looking at the
doom and gloom and really looking at it
with open eyes
and seeing where we are and i do that
not because i want to be unhappy or
i'm a masochist but i want to do it
because
i want to see where we are and then i
want to fix it as much as i can and
here's where the arctic is so important
this place that seems so remar remote at
the top of the world home to four
million people on a planet of
you know seven and a half billion
is telling us things
uh if we watch and and observe carefully
enough about how
quickly
the diversity in the system the
structure of a system can change
you can lose
huge volumes of ice we can lose
uh or change the the entire nature of of
plant communities as they grow taller
because it's warmer in summer
we can lose entire
populations of reindeer because it rains
one day in in december and it forms an
ice layer on the ground that they need
to access to forage through the rest of
the winter
um so we see massive die-offs of of
reindeer and svalbard and norway and
other places these are all things that
these these either whether they're
singularities or whether they're rapid
changes over a period of say a decade
we've now observed the systems for long
enough to know where they're headed and
they're headed they're headed in a bad
play scale right but so so but we can
learn from that well we can but first of
all we really need to know how bad it is
so first of all looking at the arctic
unfun fact number one we have lost in
the last 40 years 50 of arctic summer
sea ice
in terms of volume of the same ice we
have lost 75
of that ice in terms of old ice so
multi-year ice we have lost 95 percent
of that so that is a massive alarm bell
and it's not just an alarm bell for the
polar bear or for the inland
community here in greenland it is an
alarm bell for the way the rest of us
lead our lives because the arctic
affects the global climate system it
affects extreme weather in the
mid-latitudes so
storms too much heat drought wildfires
polar vortex coming in floods too much
rain
changes on agricultural
crop growing seasons
sea level rise i mean it just affects a
lot of what we're of of how we live our
life far away from the arctic and that
that is just one of the big systems
that's under um incredible pressure
right so if we want to really look at
the doom and gloom in september at the
un meetings
uh in 2019 the un uh what the club of
rome launched
a planetary emergency so that's the
first time that a prestigious
organization like the club of rome and
global scientists
actually declared a planetary emergency
it's never been done before i was one of
the contributors and that really sucks i
have to say it like to spend the summer
before that knowing we're declaring a
planetary emergency is really hard
because you're with your own families
and you think wow
doom and gloom that is not good news and
only by actually looking at it for the
reality
i think we can dig ourselves out of it
so the doom and gloom is important from
not a let's give up but from a let's get
moving
let's fix this and let's fix it now yeah
the complacency of of of our actions so
far is just leading us further down this
path
[Music]
let's take a step back and go
okay but what
how does humanity need to shift in being
this species on this planet how do we
need to think differently as a species
that's revolutionary and completely
different than what got us to this point
in those years in 2050 and 2100 with
these immense changes taking place
across the globe i think we have to
become systemic again and we have to be
embedded in the natural system and then
we have to figure out how do we govern
in a totally new way
so right now we're governing whether
it's our families our communities our
companies or our nation states really
with from a self-interested it's us
versus them perspective we cannot do
that in a complex system we will not be
able to do that in a future earth that
has any dimension of fundness to it
we're either on the catastrophic future
earth and that's really survival of
of of the fittest side
um or we're in a future earth where
we've actually learned to be to to
govern much more systemically and that
will be a really different way of doing
that probably technology can massively
help us on that because we can figure
out what's going on in other places and
somehow integrate those
data points into it but technology can
help us but
isn't there a fundamental compassion gap
there
because you're talking about like
companies and countries not operating
out of self-interest
i mean
that's crazy talk i mean look at all of
these kind of right-wing people being
elected all over the globe that are
talking up nationalistic self-interest
as they're
you know people want jobs they want more
money in their pockets they're feeling
over taxed they're feeling overburdened
they want to take care of their families
and they're listening to these kind of
reactionary demagogues and voting them
into office but you're saying we need to
go in a completely different way isn't
it isn't the problem more spiritual of
of like a deep
like a deep soul compassion for whomever
might be suffering in some place else on
the planet and how do we all band
together and survive as a species
i mean ultimately we need to find these
solutions ourselves i don't think
there's going to be
little green men from outer space that
come down and hand us a recipe book on
you know how to save the planet they
wouldn't be what if they were little
green women
sorry
little green little green persons come
down but they will be there
there will be so you know
we have to save ourselves and i think
those conversations are taking place i
think they're taking place more visibly
it may not be reflected in the
governance structures that we have right
now and or the people that are
running those those those those
governance structures but there is a
change taking place there's an awareness
that
without some change we're going to be on
a very
uh poor path
and and i you know i like what you're
saying about compassion
and i think
that when we bring the heart back in
to science
to economics and to government
that's a much more beautiful future
place
and i think that that's a place that
most of us would like to be in
almost every day of the week i go up to
my university campus and i s you know go
into a classroom or walk hallways with
young people and you know what
they have a concern and an awareness and
a sense of optimism and a curiosity
and a drive to try to change the way
things are so maybe
um
maybe it it takes a change of the
generation
that
can affect the type of actions that will
be needed but
at the university right now i'm very
optimistic with the the students that
that are sitting in my classroom that
challenge me on all of these things and
are seeking the knowledge and the
understanding to make those changes
happen
[Music]
okay well
that actually wasn't so bad like it i
think maybe i'll stop digging my little
hole
stop digging your mole hole during my
mold hole yeah it is it is really bad it
is it is really bad and at the same time
there is hope and there is an enormous
challenge awaiting humanity not a
country not the united states not
finland not spain but
there is a challenge awaiting seven and
a half billion people on this planet you
feel like like
joe schmoe american
i'm living in topeka like well
well i mean i guess i could trade in my
gas car for an electric car and i might
put up some solar panels and maybe i
could eat some less meat but what what
good is me i'm just one person there's
seven billion people so this is part of
the problem with climate change is
because we need seven billion people to
make that same decision we really need
people
to you know drive electric to put solar
panels on their house to stop eating
meat to stop consuming so much to plant
more trees and to fight for the health
of the environment and politically to
fight for policy
that
stops um our dependence on on oil and
gas and coal especially coal just needs
to be banned outright and we have to
fight to ban it it's it is it's
absolutely the worst
i've had a couple of cousins of mine
that i've taken to rehab
okay from drug addiction so
if you're addicted to something
you can get out of the addiction
earlier and easier and you're definitely
going to suffer negative consequences or
you can
total your car and hit someone and lose
all your teeth and be bleeding out of
your eyes and go into a spasm and lose
your
left arm because of sepsis and you can
go the hard way and that's the choice
that humanity has
i i just i i hear you and i just can't
help but think that we're we've already
decided the hard way
like no addiction is a really good
metaphor for this thank you and maybe
i've just seen too many movies but isn't
it usually like when you wake up naked
in a gutter uh and and you've got
nothing left then you're finally like
you know what i i ought to do something
about my life and some people hit bottom
much less than that some people just
pass out at a party and their friends
tell them hey you got to do something
about your drinking or your drug use and
that's their bottom and they turn things
around so the question is and i'm glad
to hear you say that this experience
made you think that no maybe there is
hope after all
but
have do we have to hit bottom first as a
planet is that when we hope happens we
are definitely going to hit bottom it's
just how bad of a bottom is it going to
be and i've never said the word bottom
so many times in my life bottom bottom
bottom bottom bottom i'm going to hit
your bottom oh
yeah well
[Music]
what do you think listeners do you think
it's possible
do you think that we can make the
changes necessary on a global level do
you think what rain said is right that
it whether we can do it on the global
level or not it all starts with the
individual that you yourself are gonna
make a commitment that you're going to
make the changes necessary in order to
be able to inhabit a livable world let
us know what you think find us on
socials reza aslan and rayne wilson make
sure to use the hashtag metaphysical and
if you have some kind of climate
manifesto or ideas about climate that
you think can change the world we
definitely want to hear about that we
can all do something we have to do
something we are going to be feeling
these effects more and more through the
decades so get busy and just to be clear
if you have the solution to our climate
crisis sitting in a drawer somewhere
probably don't just email us
yeah that's my
sense
get it get it out there get it out there
that's what i'm trying to say help us
out uh thank you so much to our guests
uh dr david hick and dr gail whiteman
keep fighting a good fight both of you
love you both love you greenland
and uh we'll catch you next week if
there is a next week
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yaz harris lane mick demaria
hashem himself and dj lubel
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is produced by
amy s choi and rebecca lehrer of the
mashup americans associate producers are
jocelyn gonzalez lindsey crowell sarah
pellegrini mary phillips sandy and
shelby
sandlin original music by jeff tang and
scott
[Music]
tang where in the world is reindeer
wilson lula's at greenland lulas at
greenland
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you